[Música]
[Aplausos]
en este siglo cuando no sabemos un
concepto lo primero que hacemos pues es
desbloquear el móvil abrir internet y
preguntar a google google qué es la
desobediencia inteligente y normalmente
pues nos aparece su buscador y lo
primero que nos aparece es el concepto
en wikipedia según wikipedia la
desobediencia inteligente hace
referencia a un animal la asistencia de
estrado que pesa las normas de su dueño
pues va en contra para el beneficio de
éste este concepto se viene utilizando
desde 1936 y el ejemplo más claro que
tenemos es el del perro guía que
imagínate que va aún pues una persona
invidente por la calle se para chocar
con una pared o se va a caer por unas
escaleras aunque esté invidente le
indica a su perro que se va por ahí éste
es desobediente inteligente y cambia de
dirección para salvarle
la desobediencia inteligente nos hace
individuos más libres nos desata de una
sociedad donde la mayoría de las veces
nos enseñan a pensar a actuar y soñar
como todos
nos enseñan lo que está bien nos enseñan
lo que está mal
vídeos bajo reglas continuas y si
desobedecemos nos enseñan que está mal
pero qué pasa si un día yo tengo una
idea
no me quiero quedar en el y si hubiese
hecho esto y si yo hubiese hecho aquello
me quiero estampar contra la pared
vivimos en una sociedad donde pues no se
suele escuchar y vivimos bajo bajo esa
presión continua es verdad que es
importante escuchar la idea valorar esa
idea es mucho más importante pero lo que
es más importante de todo es probarla y
llevarla a cabo
cuanta gente hoy en día no es feliz
cuántos estudiantes hay matriculados en
carreras que no son sus sueños y cuánta
gente trabaja en sus puestos de trabajo
en los cuales pues no son felices o no
están llenos
pues yo les digo que al final pues
luchen por sus sueños aplaudir a
aquellos hijos que desobedecen a sus
padres que quieren luchar por lo que
quieren estudiar
hijos aplaudida aquellos padres que os
dejan estudiar lo que realmente queréis
porque ellos se darán cuenta que en este
momento la autoridad no tiene sentido
al final padres los que tendréis que
hacer es apoyarles ayudarles y darles
los medios para que vuelen y persigan
sus sueños
os voy a contar una metáfora que bueno
me inventado y creo que ejemplifica muy
bien esto
un fruto crece mucho mejor más grande
más sano a su libre albedrío
cuando crece y vemos ese gran aspecto
que tiene cae lo cogemos nos apetece
comerlo y cuando mordemos tiene un sabor
fantástico ese sabor es el sabor del
orgullo
este soy yo
se me veía venir a ese pequeño
siempre he tenido las cosas muy claras
es verdad que muchas veces tengo mis
dudas como todo el mundo pero busco a
esa persona que se realmente lo que me
va a decir porque en el fondo lo tengo
claro
cuando era pequeño mientras todos los
niños en el cole querían ser astronautas
bomberos profesores yo quería ser
diseñador y joaquín cortez
porque joaquín cortez porque era el
único bailarín que conocía cuando era
pequeño y en este caso no sería los
paradigmas de la sociedad y bueno pues
se rían de mí
cuando creció un poquito más me acuerdo
que siempre mi abuela me decía niño tú
qué haces estudias o trabajas abuela
estudio y que estudias pues para ser
diseñador de moda uy qué es eso a lo que
le interrumpía siempre una de mis tías
madre para hacer trajes y esas cosas y
no no no tú qué vas a estudiar eso sí
eso no da cuartos tú tienes que ser
médico abogado o algo mejor
y hablando de diseñador de moda
preguntaréis qué es eso de la moda pues
como al principio de la charla os decía
cuando no sabemos un concepto pues
buscamos desbloqueamos el móvil pues
según wikipedia viene de del francés
mode y del latín modus que significa en
modo medida ya no se está diciendo un
poco por dónde van los tiros la moda es
un conjunto de prendas y complementos
que lleva una persona le definen y
definen sus ideas al final durante ese
periodo de tiempo que las lleva marca en
tendencia y marc y enmarcan en ese
contexto histórico
al final para mí la moda no es ropa son
prendas que en su conjunto transmiten
ese mensaje y podríamos decir que ese
mensaje que transmite es la carta de
presentación de esa persona
la moda pues a pesar que en países como
en españa no estaba muy valorado es en
otros países como francia una de las
primeras potencias económicas es también
una de las industrias que más nadadores
a contracorriente tiene y bueno la moda
tiene pues muchos factores que nos
permite por ejemplo jugar con ella un
día por ejemplo te levantas y te vas a
ver a tu jefe pero sin corbata y una
camisa así chula o puedes ir a un acto
de largo de corto o incluso a una boda
de blanco siempre y cuando pues que
seamos educados la moda al final tiene
ese poder psicológico de que si por
ejemplo un día te levantas y no te
apetece hacer nada no te apetece ir a
trabajar al finalizar es que no no salgo
de casa abres el armario y ves el pezón
esa pieza que al final te ha costado
tanto tiempo ahorrar o que con tanta
ilusión te has comprado pues la moda
tiene ese poder de cambio emocional que
de repente te la pones y te cambia el
día de no apetece te hacer nada y tener
ese mal día te apetece hacer todo
de no querer ir a trabajar te apetece
hasta ir a trabajar de que no te vea
nadie a que te mire todo el mundo
al final la moda tiene ese poder que
solo las piezas más especiales tienen
os voy a poner un ejemplo esta es una
foto de los 50 de un desfile de dior
es el new look la nueva silueta que en
ese momento pues él inventó y puso de
moda es característica por esa cinturita
de avispa y la falda de vuelo pues se
cuenta que en ese desfile todas las
clientas y asistentes que fueron
salieron del desfile pues bajando se las
faldas y al final sufrieron ese cambio
emocional porque no querían llevar
puesto lo que llevaban al final querían
ese nuevo look que había inventado dios
la moda aparte de hacer estos cambios
tiene el poder de cambiar los cánones de
belleza establecidos hasta el momento
seguimos con los 50 pues una del el
canon de belleza de los 50 era el y
marilyn monroe pero y hoy en día al
final los cánones de belleza cambian
porque la gente empatiza con otros tipos
de cuerpo y hoy en día podríamos hablar
que el canon de belleza es las hermanas
de esta señorita que es kim kardashian
al final el cuerpo establecido hasta
entonces con la similitud de la gente ha
cambiado ya es un cuerpo más bajito pues
con muchas más curvas y al final incluso
ellas han llegado a inventar el famoso
este contour y no que hemos vivido en
tantos vídeos de youtube en tantas
revistas una forma nueva de maquillarse
la moda aparte de cambiar cánones
también tiene el poder de transmitir
mensajes muchas de estas celebrities y
la moda no serían nada al final la moda
que llevan transmiten quién son ellas o
el mensaje que quieren decir por ejemplo
aquí tenemos a lady gaga que sería lady
gaga sin sin ese halo de libertad sin
esas prendas que al final te dice ese
mensaje de que tú mismo vive como
quieras y ponte lo que quieras y además
apoyando a colectivos como el ltte bq
también tenemos al que un antes y un
después que se produjo en la moda como
mensaje que fue este épico corsé de
pechos picudos de
de madonna
y bueno llegando a este punto
como se ha explicado que es la moda un
poco en general
lo que hace la moda te cambia cambian
los cánones de belleza transmite mensaje
dice quién eres tú para mí la moda parte
de todo esto sobre todo esa artesanía
muchas veces la moda va asociada a este
concepto de lujo y de prendas caras pero
no quiero que os quedéis con esto al
final la moda es artesanía
hoy en día pues vivimos en
pues debiendo nos educar con el planeta
y debéis ser conscientes de que salió en
estudio recientemente que la moda es la
segunda industria que más contamina el
planeta al final nos han metido en un
bucle de querer constantemente estrenar
ropa de que lo que pones ya no se lleva
necesitas comprar más y ahora que
conocéis esto yo suelto pues este
conocimiento para ser un poquito más
conscientes y libres de decidir a qué
queréis aportar
al final la moda aparte de
bueno de todo esto
y del lujo
tiene tiene no sobre el precio de
artesanía sino el precio de la
exclusividad al final para mí la moda de
una forma de lujo no es gastarte mucho
dinero o adquirir una pieza de un gran
importe sino saber que estás comprando
algo que te lo están haciendo para ti y
qué estudillo y de nadie más cuántas
personas pueden llevar puestos lo que
ahora lleváis o llevo yo puesto miles no
nos ha ocurrido muchas veces que vais
por la calle y vais a andando y veis a
alguien con lo mismo que lleváis
vosotros
qué vergüenza no muchas veces vais por
la calle también y podéis ver algo hay
pues mira este vestido lo tengo yo ay
pues esto me lo puse el otro día pues al
final os propongo tienda veis un poquito
más porque queramos o no a todo el mundo
nos nos gusta sentirnos con mucha más
personalidad
antes de clausurar mi charla os quería
brindar la oportunidad el conocimiento y
el saber de que seáis desobedientes
inteligentes como consumidores de moda
al final al conocer todo todos estos
beneficios y contras que tiene la moda
pues deben ser un poco inteligentes
indagar en más marcas tienen más
personalidad y realmente valorar todo
esto que hay detrás
los acordes de mi abuela
pues aquella que decía que para que iba
a estudiar yo esto si no servía de nada
pues ojalá mi abuela ahora mismo fuese
consciente para decirle abuela no soy lo
que has querido que tú sé que ellos que
tú seas que yo sea no pero pese a ser
lo que yo he querido ser sé que estás
orgullosa de mí muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]